good afternoon in your life now
good afternoon and welcome to this
webinar
um let's give a couple of
um seconds uh maybe a bit less than a
minute to
put the rest of the the attendees there
are currently logging in so we will
start in a few seconds thank you
foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is
Vincent Garnier I'm the director general
of the ftth council Europe we are the
organizer of the webinar series and
today's session is titled single versus
dual box setup how to make the right
choice this webinar will be presented by
our partner iskotep
and maybe before we start I will say a
few words about the ftth council we are
a trade Association uh founded in 2004
our mission is to promote the use of
full fiber connectivity full fiber
Network throughout Europe we regroup
over 150 member company
vendors operators and also investors the
entire value chain behind the
development of ftth Networks
we have multiple activities
um expert advice to policy makers we
produce studies reports we also operate
as a networking platform we have our
annual conference and like today we
organize a webinar to share with our
audience some insightful element about
our industry and the ftth technology
so this webinar is part of a series of
webinar we conduct more or less every
month
we provide our audience with
industry information about Market
information from our members
you can access the replay of this
webinar on our website but also access
the replay of all preview sessions so
don't hesitate to go back to the ftth
council website to see all the replay of
the previous webinar but also subscribe
and register to the next webinar which
will come in the future
and now maybe just some practical
housekeeping information as I said the
session is recorded you will receive
access to the replay via a link provided
to you by email after this session
uh you can also immediately access the
slide deck which our speaker will will
go through
um it's available in PDF format on the
handout section of the platform so you
can go there click download and
immediately have access to the PDF we
are using today
very important this is an interactive
session at the end of the session we
will at the end of the hour we will have
time to take some of your questions do
not hesitate to use the question box in
on the platform
to to type your question as we progress
into the the webinar and we will take as
much as we can this question at the end
of the session those who have not been
addressed for lack of time we will
address them later and go back to you by
email so don't hesitate to ask as many
questions as you want every single of
them will be addressed either live at
the end of the session or later by email
so without further Ado let me introduce
you to mitcha Golia he is a business
development director of the iskatel
Broadband business unit
he has a PHD in telecommunication
engineering at the University of
Ljubljana in Slovenia and it comes with
17 years
of product and portfolio management role
as well as business development and
customer relation activity within
scriptel so a very in-depth
understanding of our Market
and as you can see on the slide there is
the the agenda of the presentation I let
you read through that but I won't maybe
as an introduction to say that the topic
of today is particularly relevant from
the point of view of the ftth council
Europe
we see that in Europe ftth deployment
reach a coverage of 50 percent
in time of home past but the penetration
level the number of household being
connected to the internet on full fiber
network is only 25 percent
it reflects a tack up of 50 a lot still
is to be made to convince uh household
to subscribe to internet services based
on fiber Network and one of the key
elements is really the quality of
in-home connectivity it's all very good
to bring one gigabit or potentially
maybe 10 gigabit to the doorstep of the
house but what really matters is that
the end device TV screen iPad tablet
receives the maximum of that available
bandwidth and this is where in-home
connectivity plays a very big part it's
too often a bottleneck in the network
and that point should really be the
focus for more service provider moving
forward
and
the second element which makes this
session particularly relevant is that
you will see that Mitchell will bring
that topic from also the perspective of
the evolution of our Market where Open
Access Network are developing very fast
and we'll point out what technology is
best adapted to that situation which
require flexibility between operators
and finally I noticed in this
presentation that he finishes with a
note on the importance of sustainability
and that has become also an essential
story within the The Narrative developed
by the ftth council but also a main
target of policy maker in Europe
Telecom Network are essential enabler of
the future sustainable Society but it's
also important that our industry
reduces carbon footprint so any small
decision in terms of choice of
Technology can have a very big impact on
how our Network can be as possible
sustainable
so with this consideration I would like
to leave the floor to our speaker and I
wish you a very good session don't
forget to ask question and I'll come
back to you later for the Q a thank you
Vincent thank you very much thank you
very much for the introduction
a very warm welcome also from my site so
today's discussion will be in the
challenge of single box versus dual box
deployment but I would like to start
with challenges that we have in the
Telco industry
so these remains practically forever and
will continue to do the continue to do
so so of course every operator would
like to improve the total cost of
ownership so by reducing the capital
investment by reducing the cost of
operational activities by increasing the
outposts or revenues per user protect
their subscriber base reduce the churn
and of course improve the customer
satisfaction but let's first see what is
really going on with the Broadband
Networks if we see let's say the traffic
how the traffic is growing through the
years we could see that practically it's
quite steady growth of 30 or even a
little bit more
but one thing is also more important to
see in this chart that the majority of
traffic is not uh consumed or produced
by the personal computers like in the
past but it goes to the mobile devices
so the devices which typically connects
through the Wi-Fi networks wireless
networks and that means like a Vincent
Mansion also a big change in customer
home so what kind of local network do we
have inside of our homes how we are
consuming this uh this bandwidth and
further on if we look if we look on the
let's say average speeds that we have
today in the Broadband Network so the
median speed for the global population
is around 70 megabits in download and 30
megabits in upload
while the average speed test done on the
o-class speed test website shows that
globally the numbers are around 140
megabits in the download and 78
megabytes megabits in upload there are
of course
countries where the speeds are even
higher like in Singapore around 300
megabits per second but the question is
do we really need such a high speeds why
what are the services running behind
that needs such a high high-speed
internet
and on the other hand we have some
governments or institutions bodies which
are explaining us what is let's say the
speed uh which is minimum to to satisfy
the normal needs and in the European
Union we have gigabit Society Vision
which predicts that till 2025 we should
have at least 100 megabits per household
and let's say in average if in a
household is four persons that gives 25
per person which is also quite good
related to what FCC so the US
body is defining as a minimum bandwidth
per person
but why then we have such higher speeds
as mentioned before us are tested or
offered today is by the different telcos
well we are using Broadband to access
different kind of services of course the
most data is consumed by different video
Services we have today like ultra high
definition video we have
4K television we have different kind of
over the top Services we are using video
conferencing like today for this webinar
uh but those Services typically use like
like we saw in the previous slide around
25 megabits should be sufficient or 100
per typical household to work from home
to do all of these cloud services but we
see that operators are offering more we
saw also from the speed test before that
consumers have higher higher speeds what
is really behind do we have a service
besides the speed test that needs to
that needs such a high speed and the
question is and the answer to this
question is yes so the service that will
consume a higher bandwidth is coming
it's called metaverse with virtual
reality and argumented reality this is a
big business
so this business is planned to
this the worth of this business for 2028
is planned more than 250 billion dollars
so it's really impressive to see those
Services how how they run how we will
play have fun work in the virtual world
how to improve our business process
sales processes and so on
but those Services of virtual reality
they need different requirements from
the network perspective and let's see
what are the minimum requirements to
have such services
uh today the this glasses for uh
using the virtual reality or argumented
reality are still in development phase
so they are not uh what should be the
final uh the final goal uh today for
running such Services you need around 25
megabit which is the the average but as
you can see on this chart the end goal
to have really good experience so
visually and also especially from the
latency perspective so that the the
environment will adapt like you move
around your head and so on then we would
need to bandwidth more than one gigabit
per user
and if we were having average phone like
two three users four users we will need
several gigabits of broadband speed and
this is actually driving our development
as Telco vendors and Telco operators
while we are building fiber networks
while we are building
um better products allowing uh higher
speeds and why also different kind of
standards are being developed
so that comes to the first question let
me open the first poll
so
share
I hope you can see it so I would like to
ask the audience
if you can answer to our first question
so do you plan to deploy 10 gigabit
access technology in 2023 so
if we have
audience so our guests from Telco
operators or from some other industry or
if you are just a normal Broadband user
do you think you will use 10 gigabit
technology or deploy thank you
technology next year
so in the meantime that we are waiting
to get some results I would ask Vincent
so what is your opinion
what is fdth Council thinking about
adoption of 10 gigabit technology
well Richard thanks thanks for the
question we are seeing uh quite a few
operator uh throughout Europe mostly
alternative operator using a 10 gigabit
Services as a differentiator today so
and we are also seeing increasingly
uh 10 gigabit uh Pawn technology xjs
Pawn uh being gradually implemented so I
think it's um it's no longer you know
something of the future it becomes
something for today at least in terms of
infrastructure availability
so I think we have a little problem with
showing the pull so it's showing that it
does not show the results so
looks like there was a problem on my
side perhaps I clicked too quickly
uh anyhow so okay we will try to uh try
to
um continue and answer on this
later or let's say discuss a little bit
later let's let's continue with our
presentation we have two more pools and
perhaps later on we could share the
result so probably my fault that we
close it a little bit too fast
okay if we continue uh so I will
continue with the technology Trends and
uh and the evolution so how the
standardization bodies are answering to
this uh topic of providing higher speeds
um so in the access part so the most
used technology today is the pawn
technology passive Optical Networks and
here we have a very old technology
g-pawn is called which is mainly used in
in different countries around the globe
uh this uh standard was developed way
way ago but today is the most actual
technology the most interesting
technology 6GS Pawn which is like
Winston said it's being deployed right
now it offers 10 gigabit symmetrical
speeds and this will be the main
technology in the upcoming year studios
in the meantime of course the
standardization bodies are developing
already faster standards faster
Technologies so 50 gigabit Pawn is being
standardized and we plan that by 2024
this technology will also be mature
enough to to be used in real Networks
and uh yeah then also the migration will
come to to faster Technologies but as
mentioned before even more important are
the Technologies for the in-home
um in-home connectivity and Wi-Fi as far
as line is what I would say the most
important technology and that one is
evolving also quite fast so uh before we
could see that different kind of
standards were developing every four or
five years but recently uh last four
years this the adoption and the
development of new standards has
accelerated
and we have now Wi-Fi 6 which is the
standard for wireless LAN which is
widely deployed practically I I don't I
know almost every operator is using now
this technology that is also a Wi-Fi 6E
and extending to 6 gigahertz bands which
is becoming
uh interesting now on the market and the
development of Wi-Fi 7 started Wi-Fi 7
standard also started
it's planned that this standard will be
ratified next year or early of 2024 but
we already see first the product for
chipsets being available or developed
right now
and if we go a little bit in in some
details of those two latest standards
Wi-Fi standards so Wi-Fi 6E is actually
using the same technology in Principle
as Wi-Fi six it also only extends the
band so besides the using the five
gigahertz band which is normal for
previous version of Wi-Fi now we have
available also the six gigahertz band
and in U.S they were more generous with
the bandwidth so they are located 1.2
gigahertz of the bandwidth while in
Europe we have available only 500
megahertz
and since this spectrum is quite clear
we expect very good
performance of the devices using Wi-Fi
6E
mentioned before also Wi-Fi 7 is being
developed it brings the even higher
capacity wider channels
more better modulation even more spatial
streams but one let's say one technology
used in this wi-fi 7 is very important
or the most important is so-called
multi-link operation
what is this uh this is a service as you
will see on the next slide that really
helps to improve the robustness the
capacity and also reduces the latency
significantly so how this multi
link operation works
so in the past or let's say current
Technologies like Wi-Fi 6 the device
communicate only in one band at the same
time so if you if the device is
connected on five gigahertz band then
it's communicating only on the five
gigahertz band with Wi-Fi 7 the devices
could establish separate channels so on
2.4 Giga on 5 Giga and on 6 gigahertz
and this will of course significantly
boost the speed
but even more so since today if the
device wants to switch from one band to
another this takes some time roughly
around half a second
by using multi-link operation this
switching is practically instantly so we
are talking less than one millisecond so
this will also significantly reduce the
latency and therefore Wi-Fi 7 will be
one of the
the most important technology for using
metaverse Services as presented
previously
okay now hopefully this tool will go on
so let me open another Pool
so I have to click just once
uh so now you can see it
so the question is do you use Wi-Fi 6
technology already today
so I have couple of devices at my home
Vincent how about you
I'm afraid I'm I'm not very well
equipped in terms of Wi-Fi 6 but how is
it going on your side is do you see a
real shift towards Wi-Fi says compared
to to the previous Technologies
yes so
um from his cartel perspective we are a
vendor of different CPE products and I
have to say that for example last year
Wi-Fi 6 was representing I don't know 20
of let's say our sales but this year
this shift was really significantly and
it's coming to half or even more than
half of devices that we were shipped
we'll use the transition is really
taking place uh this year and yes it's
going uh it's going very fast and as
mentioned so we already see some
interest for Wi-Fi 6c so extending to
the 6V Health band
um next year I think uh first product
set first demand is expected on the
market but we expect for each of these
new standard the adoption rate is
shorter so if before we need
I don't know two three years that the
new standard became
to Prevail the market share now this
time has reduced significantly and shift
can come already in one year one and a
half years so something like this so
it's really going much faster so I guess
maybe maybe triggered also with the
pandemic and the importance of of
quality of in-home connectivity for for
many households sorry um that you reveal
the result of the
they both
okay so the audience is voting I think
we collected a majority of the votes
let's see the results so
um
okay so what we have 55 answered yes 30
no then 50 percent they don't know
um okay so yeah this I would say it's
quite related to our sales number so
um it's it's really
becoming a the main technology in in
Wi-Fi
as we expected okay let's continue with
our presentation
maybe uh just a reminder that questions
are more than welcome
um so please don't hesitate to use the
question box to to ask questions this is
to give or presenter the opportunity to
to drink a little bit
um but yeah please send your your
question we will address them at the end
of the session thanks a lot
okay and now to the main topic of
today's presentation so single box and
dual box deployment so
um what is this so and what we have to
consider
so when we are talking and comparing
different kind of approaches so we have
to consider a couple of things that were
presented before so what is the typical
lifetime of Technology
and if you saw before for example for
the one technology when we compared
g-pawn and XTS pawn it took more than 10
years that we switched from one
technology to another
on the other hand in the home
connectivity
we saw that Wi-Fi standards are evolving
much faster
so every two year now we will have a new
Wi-Fi standard
I just read an article already
describing what's what technologies are
considering about Wi-Fi 8
so some Engineers already started
working on this
uh but there are also other aspects so
we have to see
uh what kind of functionalities for the
home networking we will use
um where these functions will be run so
like this layer two layer 3 function so
also we have to consider some regulatory
aspects like Open Access networks which
are defining that a clear separation
between a network and service provider
has to be done so let's see some of
those challenges a little more in
details in the single box deployment is
very simple we have the access
technology like in this case the the
g-pawn technology and just one device at
customer home so a home Gateway
if we have a dual box deployment at
customer home there are two devices
first one which terminates the optical
Network and provides a standard
interface like ethernet and then another
box which offers the services so where
it's the Wi-Fi router where you can
access via through the wireless network
you have some other connect connection
points like USB interface or you can
connect a phone and and so on a setup
box and and so on
the third part of dualbox deployment is
also a scenario where as mentioned
before we have so-called Open Access
Network so this separation between
Network providers and service provider
when one network provider builds the
network
and then different service providers
isps are offering different services to
the end users and here typically there
is a dual box approach because the
service provider box is being managed by
the service provider while this network
termination is being managed by the
network provider
okay so if we compare a single box
versus dual box
both options have pluses and minuses
with single box sure one box is always
cheaper than two boxes that's that's
fact
so the costs of single box are lower
um there is only one device to manage
but there are also some drawbacks and
the biggest drawback is in shorter
lifetime as I said so Wi-Fi technology
changes much faster than Optical
technology
then also fiber does not necessarily
come to the living room of a house
so if it comes to the basement or to the
attic this is not the optimal place
where you would put this home Gateway
from Wi-Fi perspective so the access
point or the the Wi-Fi
should be located in in a room where
you're spending most of time and to have
as the best coverage of complete home so
with single box approach this is more
challenging to achieve than on Dual box
also Optical installation in-house it's
more challenging than normalcad 5 Cat6
installation
and I've mentioned before there is also
Open Access
regulation which practically demands to
help the Dual box
but let's see also this comparison from
another perspective let's let's see from
business perspective because everybody
loves to see and count money so does
this make sense to go to dual box
approach with uh from business
perspective
and before we go to the calculation we
have to see let's say a couple of um
preconditions or let's say what what we
will put to the equation
one technology we see in the past that
it changes every 10 years on average
okay let's say that if GS Pawn will be
shorter than Japan that 50 gig Pawn will
come sooner so let's say between 7 and
10 years
while the land technology especially
Wi-Fi here changes much faster so we saw
from new standards are coming every two
years
but let's put on average three to four
years between we will have to change the
device because of the Wi-Fi technology
and then let's make also some
assumptions about the pricing so
um let's say that a simple Network
termination a Bridge cost one unit
so later on you can enter here your
exact numbers so
um and that's a home Gateway a Wi-Fi
router costs about two units so it's
twice more expensive than a simple
Bridge
while the device so home Gateway which
has also the optical interface costs 2.5
units
there is also important to know what is
let's say or um
assume what is the cost of
installation at customer home so how
much a truck roll or a visit of engineer
or technician at the
at subscribers home how much it costs
this varies a lot so there are countries
which with more expensive labor force
there are countries with cheaper labor
force so the numbers can vary but let's
see how this looks like if we put these
numbers to the equation so if we have a
single box deployment and we say every
three and a half years we will have to
replace it because a new Wi-Fi standard
will come so and this is let's say our
capex investment costs if we add here
the Dual box approach where we have to
change the first box so the converter
every nine years
and we are replacing the Wi-Fi router at
the same time so every three and a half
years we can see that the capital
investment is practically very similar
that is not much difference
but if we put in this equation also the
operational part so when replacing the
optical unit you cannot send the device
by post but a technician has to visit
um
a customer and replace the device
because it's a
sensitive technology of optical
connectors and so on and there is a
necessary track role in this case so if
we are comparing this with
um
dualbox approach where the Wi-Fi router
can be distributed by post or by some
some other service and you don't need to
send your technician
the difference becomes more obvious and
this is actually the main benefit why
operators are considering for dualbox
there are of course also other points as
mentioned before so regulatory Wi-Fi and
so on but business of course is is the
most important
um of course here if you have different
numbers you can put a different number
to the to this
model and calculate your Breakeven
points but we can see that
dualbox approach is really more cost
efficient from the total cost of
ownership perspective
but there are other aspects it's not
just business and I think we have to
open also the sustainability aspect
we did a great step forward with fiber
networks which are really using much
less energy than previous copper based
Technologies or even point-to-point
Optical Network so
this carbon footprint is reducing
significantly with latest Fiber
Technologies but more important is also
if you look it from this single box
versus dual box approach if we can
prolong the life cycle of the equipment
such in the Dual box case so the optical
termination unit remains in the network
not just for three and a half years but
for 10 15 years and you are replacing
only the parts that needs to be replaced
not everything then we can do something
also for the environment and this
reduces the electronic waste so we know
that European commission
already defined some
guidelines what to do to reduce the
electronic wastes for example changing
the Chargers for the mobile phones to
USBC that will be only one type used and
already from that great savings is
planned to achieve
but if we
follow this also with the CPU devices
and instead of traditional power
supplies we switch to USBC power
supplies which in this criteria we will
do in the latest generation we are also
helping to reduce electronic waste then
there will be no need to throw away a
charger at power supply but you could
use the old one also with the with the
new devices
further on
uh it's very important for us to do more
sustainable products how to reduce power
consumption with some energy saving mode
like switching off Wi-Fi during the
night if you don't need it
using recycled materials
for plastic housing or
designing the product to be recyclable
so that it can be easily disassembled
and the materials used for further on
then reducing unnecessary packaging and
Plastics removing hazardous materials
and chemicals
and in this cartel we are doing already
uh in this direction so just for an
example to show we we have developed a
line of Wi-Fi mesh access points where
the housing is made of wood
and also there is no labels we use later
engraving to reduce the the labels to
reduce the chemicals for the glue and
and so on then also for the packaging we
use hay or straws to uh for this inner
buffer to to hold to protect the devices
so that really all the material is
biodegradable
and also the manuals are made on the on
the wooden uh wooden parts so we are
like we would like to make products more
sustainable and better for
um for the
environment
okay uh and there is also one more
initiative wants to do in this direction
so already in the ftth council in Vienna
in in March this year we introduced our
initiative to Mark the telecommunication
equipment with labels non-similar as in
the white goods industry so in your
refrigerators or so on so to have a
sticker where uh very on very simple way
it will be shown how much energy does
device consume and how good is comparing
to to the others or to let's say some uh
in the industry standards
and we would really like to encourage
also the industry the
other vendors the tail corporators to
support this initiative because we think
it's in benefit of all of us to have
very clear indication how much energy
the devices are consuming
and we have come to the rule number
three
uh so the third question let me open a
new one
okay I hope you can see it so the
question is what would you be willing to
pay more for an environmental friendly
sustainable product
per unit so it's a it's a question it's
not just for the Telco operators it's
also for you as a consumer if you would
see on the device that it's made of
environmental friendly
materials if it's more sustainable would
you be willing to pay more for such
product so because on the
let's say
when we are discussing everybody says
yes when it comes to the money the
things are a little different
so Vincent any comment from your site
sustainability is important for ftdh
Council yes
absolutely it's uh it's crucial at two
level first of all we we have a lot of
data showing that fiber Network are by
far the most sustainable Access Network
Technology if you compare to Copper if
you compare to hfc even if you compare
to Alternative Wireless solution like
fixed wireless access and I'm not
mentioning satellite so from that
perspective this is an argument in favor
of fiber deployment but we also think
that indirectly all high-speed
connectivity is a key enabler of
multiple application which will with
time become essential for the transition
of our society towards a lower carbon
footprint
environment and from that perspective
also it's essential that we we promote
um full fiber and thirdly
as an industry we need to do everything
at every level as you you are shown uh
on on the previous slide we need to do
everything to reduce uh bit by bit uh
carbon footprint uh at every level of
deployment and maintenance of Networks
yeah I agree this is really very
important okay the audience has voted uh
about that let's see let's close this
and share the result
okay so we have the results
I'm glad to see these results so 52
percent would pay five euros more for a
more sustainable eco-friendly product
uh this is really uh really good so uh I
have to say I'm a little surprised
because in the current discussions when
we as a vendor offer to sum up to
several operators different options you
know the procurement officers they have
different kpis than the sustainability
or the the the management which on the
corporate level many times say that they
want to be
environmentally friendly but yeah
procurement has many times different
kpis
okay uh it's uh it's this is really good
so glad to see this result so I think
it's important because uh you know at
the end even in the short term it costs
a couple
not even Euros so it could be a cents
more many times uh but we are doing
really much more for the environment for
the energy crisis so and this is really
an important issue
let's continue
okay with the slide deck and yeah we are
practically coming to the end of of this
uh presentation part so I have just
couple more slides about uh escritical
snd scratel company so what do we do and
briefly a couple words about us uh SNT
is is a company located in Slovenia
headquarter in Slovenia it has a little
less than uh 1000 employees very long
history 75 years we are present on the
market and we are offering different
kind of solutions for the ICT industry
globally present in more than 50
countries around the globe and yeah our
technology is being used by more than
100 million subscribers and what exactly
do we do uh we have different kind of
products so but the main products are
from the central office under the brand
name of escort illumia these are the
olts mainly so the optical access
of course supporting different kind of
Technologies like gponics GS pawn and
and so on and also a wide area of
different CPE products so home gateways
routers four single box dual box
deployment supporting different kind of
access technology so from gponics GS
Pawn DSL point-to-point fixed wireless
access so 5G technology and so on and
with various kinds of Wi-Fi Technologies
so this is briefly definitely if you're
interested more
we are glad that you contact us and we
could assist you further on with some
presentations or demonstration of our
equipment
and that comes to the conclusion part
so uh what are let's say the main
conclusions from this webinar for sure
we see the Technologies are evolving
with different pace on the one side it
goes so on the wide area networks on the
access part it's going it's going in
more gradual steps so steps for
uh paying from G Pawn to 10 gigabit to
50 and this technology migrates every
10 7 15 years and so on
on the other hand Wi-Fi is the key
technology in our home so it's uh
consumes or generates majority of
internet traffic
and because of the new service is coming
this technology is evolving much faster
so we have standards every two three
years a new Wi-Fi standard
consequentially of course by a new
standard we have to change the equipment
uh
and it's really from the business
perspective from sustainability
perspective also from regulatory
perspective better to use the Dual box
approach to have two devices at home and
you're replacing only the part which
needs to be replaced and keep the device
that is still good that still provides
all the necessary Services up and
running so it's more economically
variable as I said it's more sustainable
from the longer lifespan and it's also
ready for new models like Open Access
Network which is becoming important in
Europe there is a lot of so-called gray
areas where fiber is still not there it
will be deployed but those those area
will be deployed with the Dual box
dual box approach regardless in history
we have solution from one or another one
and we will continue to have this
and this finishes my presentation
so I would like now to open the
discussion with the audience so and back
the word goes back to Vincent
thank you mitcha actually we we got
quite a
few questions coming directly from the
audience so
um I'll immediately
um read the the first one which I see on
the list
um do you expect that Wi-Fi seven
devices will feature a three band
concurrent stations
yeah Wi-Fi 7 technology supports
concurrent operation this multi-link
operation and it really makes sense uh
to use Wi-Fi 7 also in the six gigahertz
band why because if you notice before
Wi-Fi 7 brings also wider channels wider
channels 320 megahertz channels which
practically we have only one such
channel on
five gigahertz band non-overlapping
while on the six gigahertz band we could
have three of them so it's practically
mandatory to use also six gigahertz band
uh with Wi-Fi 7 technology in order to
really make the benefits and higher
speed So my answer would be yes so we
expect to have tri-band devices with
Wi-Fi 7 supporting Wi-Fi 7 technology
okay I have another question from
Michael
um regarding mlo could you clarify about
band switching and latency what use case
requires band switching
yes so perhaps I can go to even a slide
before so it will be easier to show it
on a picture
um okay let me have it here oh
I was doing too fast sorry
here so um from the latency perspective
yes so since
um in Wi-Fi 7 we will have all three
bands active at the same time so the
connection would be established on the
2.4 gigahertz it will be established on
five gigahertz and also in six gigahertz
then using one if the if the capacity on
one band is available on uh let's say
other bands are more occupied then using
that one will not require a switching
from one band to another like today it
is so today uh when you have this
so-called band steering
function this band steering function
needs some time that's the
client
synchronized to another frequency to
authenticate to authorize to to
establish the the connectivity this
typically takes half a second even with
fast roaming perhaps I don't know
120 200 milliseconds definitely more
than 100 milliseconds to do this bench
steering while on Wi-Fi 7 all these
connections will be active all the time
and switching from one to another is
really much faster and therefore also
the access point so the home Gateway
could sell the package faster no need to
wait if I don't know 2.4 gigaband is
occupied it can send that package on uh
five gigahertz band or on six gigahertz
band and therefore
um use it much faster
because as you can see on this slide
when we have some interferences we have
to do the switching
and uh if all the channels are open and
active the switching is is not needed so
it's just simply transmitting on one or
another channel so it really improves
the latency
thank you
um Anning is asking you uh isn't open
access a lot easier if the service
provider can access the fiber
information in a single box scenario as
well as via I'm quoting tr069 for
example
in a dual box scenario service provider
is blind on the network side
true so when we have the Dual box
scenario there are two devices to manage
that's a fact one if we have one device
there is one device to manage that's
that's that's fact
uh however if we look it from also
another perspective on this side so
interoperability between different
vendors it's much better on dualbox
approach than on a single box while the
simple Bridge onts so this network
terminations are much more interoperable
between different Olt vendors than the
single units are home gateways why
because the omci protocol which was
which is used for the managing of of
Pawn devices defined very good this
basic part of network management and put
a lot of space open for more advanced
functionalities
from IP version 6 to different
applications running this part is always
vendor specific and therefore
interoperability is very challenging so
to answer this question it's yes and no
from first perspective it looks like
much more simple to manage just one
device but in real cases when we have
the interoperability
so when an operator typically wants to
have different vendors on the CPE and
Olt side dual box approach is actually
helping to improve this so it's easier
to manage and then use tier 069 just for
the second box management
so these are let's say real hand
experiences from the from the market
and and what about uh self installation
uh question from from Jana
uh Circle what do you mean can you can
you repeat I I don't know I mean it's a
very short question uh and Jan mentioned
uh what about self install uh I guess
it's self-insulation uh okay it is to to
set it up maybe
uh when when we come to Optical
connections you know there are several
rules we have to
um
follow so Optical connections Optical
connectors are more fragile you should
not touch them by your hands it has to
be clean no dust and so on and typically
uh and also okay you should not look to
to the optical connector if there is a
signal on
uh this is something which operators
typically don't trust end users average
end users to install optical devices by
themselves so it's practically
mandatory that this is done by a
technician a network technician that
comes to your home and connects Optical
device
while with ethernet routers Wi-Fi
routers you can buy them practically in
every store connecting an
RJ45 connector UTP cable it's not too
too difficult it's also practically
nothing can go wrong uh you cannot make
some serious mistake here and this is
something self-installation is possible
these are experiences from our operators
we are working with so they when it
comes to the
Optical Connection they always rely on
their technician when it goes to
different
I would say ethernet devices is this
mesh APS or set of boxes and so on this
is something an end user could
self-install
okay
and
if the box in the Dual set dual box
setup come from different vendors
um interoperability aspect to pay
attention attention to what about the
management of the boxes so the two
vendor situation
well I practically answered partly of
this
um uh it's actually easier so as
mentioned before so uh because it's a
clear separation the the simple Network
termination it has a very basic Network
functions practically a couple vlans and
qos has to be adjusted and this is very
very well documented and in use by the
Olt vendor so we don't see really much
issues here with interoperability while
on the other hand with the second box
the Wi-Fi router or the the home Gateway
uh if this is an Ethernet device
connected to this second box it's
typically managed through tr069 uh and
um
this is
industry standard widely deployed used
um in practice we see this more men
easier easily manageable solution than a
single box in multi-vendor environment
so it's a actually a plus uh in from
management perspective Than A minus
foreign
there is a long question I tried to
rapidly summarize it from any as well
um questioning that a two box solution
could be uh more effective in term of
energy consumption versus one box if I
if I understand well the question and
could you maybe uh reconfirm how you
calculate uh impact from that
perspective
uh-huh okay yeah so okay basically
looking so the energy consumption of two
boxes versus one box pure energy
consumption uh that we are talking about
then uh it's probably a slightly higher
power consumption of two devices than
one but the main effect comes from the
sustainability perspective uh from the
prolonged life cycle so it's a bigger
challenge today producing electronic
wastes and uh this is I think the main
the main point here of of this
sustainability not the pure energy
consumption but that the optical device
can stay in your network for 10 15 years
instead of replacing it in a single box
scenario every three four years
and
then much more electronic wastes are
being
produced and this is I think the main
approach towards this carbon footprint
and not the pure energy consumption
okay thanks a lot uh and maybe if you
can answer and I think we're running out
of time I just want to mention two
comments which are not questioned but
which were left by
participants uh Andrea is uh just want
to say thank you for the very
interesting webinar and same coming from
Peter uh thanks for for very interesting
content so I hope most of you in the
audience enjoy the information
once again you'll receive the replay you
can also download the during the the
last seconds we have late for the
session download the presentation
and I'm sure which I if there are
additional questions coming from the
audience we will forward them with
pleasure to you maybe a few few words of
of conclusion
um because I think we we have covered
quite a lot during that session I'll let
you the floor for for the wrap up and
the conclusion
yeah also from my side thank you very
much for the for the attention I hope
this uh webinar was interesting
um as mentioned so also for this uh
calculation of total cost of ownership
so if you have different numbers uh put
them into let's say this proposed
methodology and you will find your
break-even points uh we did some average
estimation between g-pawn and xgs pawn
technology and try to let's say the
price of the products uh that we used in
in this uh in this calculation
of course every operator has different
kind of exact pricing the point is in
the model so in in the model you should
calculate as well the operational costs
and then to see where is the break-even
point for you it's completely okay if
you in the your network continue to work
on a single box approach if this fits
you better if this fits your strategy
um as I said in this cartel we will
continue to produce also the single box
home gateways but we see a trend a trend
that is backed up by economic
calculations is backed up by
sustainability is backed up by regular
regulatory
influences and this is a shift towards
dualbox approach
so I hope uh it was useful for you I
would also kindly invite you to see some
of our websites or uh our let's say
social medias and we will continue to do
the webinars hopefully also continue to
do with the great partner of ftth
council and hope to see you again on our
next webinar thank you
thank you very much have a good rest of
your day and see you on our website or
on some of our events moving forward
thank you very much goodbye
goodbye